- Oh fuck, I just lassoed myself.
(laughs)
(triumphant orchestral music)
- What's up you guys, my name is Hal.
- I was very, very eager and
excited to see Wonder Woman,
I just saw it recently, like two days ago,
and my mind is blown.
- It took like a week to get tickets.
- I could not do anything
that Wonder Woman does.
- Wonder Woman is...
She's fierce.
- I've never tried lassoing
but I've definitely
done it on the dance floor.
Like, mimed it out.
(whip cracks)
But that's about it.
- Okay, so I'm about to watch this video
of how to throw a rope lasso.
- Alright, this guy
has way too much skill.
- Teach me, zaddy.
- What do people lasso anyway?
Cows?
(sighs)
- He made it seem like we're just out here
doing just a regular, smegular thing.
- Oh, shit, that actually
looks kind of crazy.
- I can do it probably.
(laughs)
(dramatic instrumental music)
- Oh my god, are you kidding?
- What the fuck, could you have just
untangled this for me, at least?
- Alright, well this looks complicated.
- I'm so confused.
- This is fucking
impossible, are you kidding?
What is it even doing?
- I feel like his hole
is way bigger though.
- And then he just...
This is simple.
- Oh.
I just hooked the damn computer.
- I don't know how Wonder Woman does this,
let alone a cowboy.
- I'm so terrified, this terrifying,
I don't want to do it anymore.
(laughs)
- I've got more shit to handle?
- Oh no.
Nope, nope, nope.
(shouts)
- Yah, yah!
- Alright, I feel even better about this,
because I've got my hand
shield, my other shield.
- Fuck you, Al.
For real.
- I honestly have no strategy.
I literally don't know what I'm doing.
- I'm gonna start with the angry one,
'cause he looks like he's pissed,
and we don't need that kind
of energy in 2017, okay?
(bell dings)
(shouts)
- I'm pretty sure I did.
- This is so hard.
How do you expect me to
do this with a shield?
(alarm buzzes)
- Yes, come around, come around!
Damn it.
(alarm buzzes)
(alarm dings)
- Bitch.
That's how you fucking lasso, right?
- The idea of using this to hurt
anyone, or fight any crime is beyond me.
I don't know how she does it.
- I mean this was really challenging.
- But yeah, just anyone
that uses a lasso rope
I have respect for now.
- I still beat the villains, so I'm
pretty proud of what I accomplished.
- So Wonder Woman's out here slaying
1,000 men, for breakfast.
- I tried.
I still love Wonder Woman,
but this is not for Katie.
Not for Katie.
(whip cracks)
- Okay so what have we learned today?
Honestly not that much.
One, lassoing is really hard to do.
Two, Wonder Woman's an amazing character,
with a lot of really awesome superpowers.
So yeah, go Wonder Woman.
And also my co-workers
really love dressing up.
(upbeat funk music)